Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of Dr. Cutters Live.
Today's episode we have Brian Morgan. Brian's not a doctor, which is kind of nice. So it's good
to have some pieces of advice from real people out there in the field that are living their life and
trying to get healthy and see the results they received, you know, doing a healthy approach to life.
So today's episode is great. Brian Morgan is our guest. Again, he's not a health professional
bill. He doesn't have a bunch of letters behind his name. But the value that he brings
to the show is really his personal testing. It is experience with a few of my favorite products
that we use in our clinic for our patients and personally I use. That's why I'm having him talk
because I have a lot of personal experience with the products that he has. He also happens
to be my cousin. And he was introducing me to his product line because he knew that I'd be
interested in it. And I know you're going to be interested in it as well. So let's listen to Brian.
Also, don't forget to hit like. That helps us. It helps other people see our video as well.
And if you're on YouTube, make sure you subscribe and hit that little alarm notification button so
that you don't miss any new episodes. Thanks so much. Again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
Thanks for joining us, Brian Morgan. Brian, give us a little background on you. I mean, I'm very familiar
with you obviously, but let's hear, you know, kind of your story, how you got involved in nutrition
and why you get. Well, well, it's interesting, Dr. Kevin, because I thought in my 20s that I knew
quite a bit in my 40s, I learned that I didn't know anything. I was the guy who was in the gym
for five days a week and a GNC gold card member and, you know, buying the tubs of protein and gain
in the muscle and thinking that that meant I was healthy. But the more I learned about the toxic
chemicals and, you know, even these products that are supposed to be healthy, the more I learned in my
late 30s and 40s, the more I was actually shocked at products that were out in the market space that
truly are a product for profit as opposed to a product to to help people. And, you know, I kind of
find that way. I had to interrupt you. You're telling me that nutritional companies are out for profit.
And not the best interest of the individual. Yeah. And of course, every company has to have a
profit or they can't stay in business, but there's a difference between bringing quality and bringing
value to the market space to earn a profit as opposed to, say, bringing marketing with very little
value to the to the human being or to the end user is the big difference. And yeah, I was shocked. You
know, it's almost, I was shocked that there weren't more governing bodies or more quality control
and nutrition. And like you said, for 20 years, I more or less participated blindly until I had,
you know, more intelligent or more educated people in my life that actually informed me of,
you know, what is of true value in the health and nutrition world, you know, value and education,
value and product as well. Okay. So now you're involved with a company. So let's make that note.
A great company. We use several of your products. Tell me a little bit about that.
So my wife and I were introduced to evolve health and we've been really excited and really proud
to be partnered with that brand for over seven and a half years, but it truly started out in necessity.
So what had happened for me is, you know, my background has always been a trait. And you know,
when I was young, I saw the level of aviation and travel and it became a commercial jet mechanic
when I was 20 years old. So I had an 18 year career commercial aviation and
that career changed and, you know, a lot of the US aircraft that legally had to be maintained in
the US are now maintained all over the world because there's no longer those regulations in place.
But, you know, don't feel bad for me when my career at Northwest Airlines edited in 2005,
I had already started a construction company. I was already prepared for that. And my construction
company exploded in a good way. So I always had something to fall back on just having the ability
as a craft person to, you know, work hard with my back and with my hands, but working hard with my
back and with my hands put me in a really tough spot. You know, when the construction industry imploded
in 2008, 2009, I found myself as a mechanic in a steel mill in 2011. Great job, great benefits,
but once again, I was using my back, my body, my hands to make a living. And it took its toll.
It took its toll in a big way and all the inflammation in my body, all the injuries I sustained over
20 plus years of being a trace person. They took its toll in a big, big way. And it got to a point
where I couldn't even get through a shift of work without consuming 20 ad bill every single day.
And my money, 20 ad bill a day just to decrease the inflammation from
abusing your body in a good way, a strong work ethic wanted to provide for your family, but
takes its toll on your joys. Absolutely. I've met so many people like me, crash men, crash women
that had given up our health for our careers. And I was going down that path. And, you know, we weren't,
you know, my, my wife has been in health and wellness her entire life. So she was guiding me along
the way. She had, you know, quite an education, but even with the, you know, anti-inflammatory,
low sugar diet, working aggressively with our chiropractor, you know, I was getting acupuncture
three times a week on my feet and ankles, cold laser therapy three times a week. And even went
through three types of orthopedic inserts of my work boots. The last pair were $800 or custom cut
for my foot and for my work boot. And all of those things we did let didn't lead me to any type
of solution whatsoever. It was still 20 ad bill every single day for five months straight. But in
addition, it was 20 or I should say for five months straight, it was my wife yelling at me every day
because she knew sooner or later that was going to lead to something worse. You know, things that
you know, Dr. Kevin, that I never knew is how horrific, say, an ad bill could be over time, you know,
what I didn't realize is that an N said, you know, a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory,
you know, what I learned is just one of them could increase a woman's chance of miscarriage by 80%.
Yeah. Well, you're doing your due diligent damage out of your liver, that's for sure.
Yeah. So 20 a day, as my wife would yell at me, it's kind of one of those things where
until you hear something enough, you just don't get it. And as I got yelled at daily,
I wasn't getting educated, I was just getting yelled at. So I didn't know how bad it was.
So she was in a, she didn't know how bad it was. And she was in an absolute panic because she
knows what that could lead to. Obviously, you have much more experience with it than I do, but I
imagine when, you know, 20 a day isn't helping somebody anymore. And for me, it was a situation where
I was in, I was in a mechanic in a steel mill and I had to do maintenance rounds every single shift.
So I'd have to walk on concrete and I'm six foot four, 240 pounds and all that pressure on my feet
took its toll. But I was saving my wedding. I was saving for my honeymoon and wedding rings.
And, you know, as anyone else, you give up that health for more hours and more money. And that's
that's what I did. But, you know, fortunately, my wife was, or my fiance at the time, my wife,
today, it was very aggressive trying to find a solution reaching out to so many different friends
across all of the USA. And the solution she ended up finding was an anti-inflammatory and all
natural. My wife is all about eating clean and natural products. And when she found a product
that she thought might work, you know, she brought it to our home. So this was seven and a half years
when the product is limitless. And you might get into more the science of that, Dr. Kevin or you
or I could add some of it. But the bottom line was this was a natural product that my wife
knew couldn't hurt me. It was guaranteed to reduce inflammation by 47% within 90 minutes.
And the studies have been proven on about that. And for me, 14 days into it, I was getting ready for
work on the 15th day. And my wife says, hey, how do your feet feel today? And I said, they feel
great. She says, did you take 20 out of the yesterday? And I said, I didn't take any. I just didn't even
realize it over 14 days. The inflammation decreased so much in my body and especially my feet.
That was my biggest challenge was my feet and ankles. Let's talk a little bit about what you
discovered. So the limitless is the brand name of a patented process of how beads are processed so
that the enzyme, the batalan enzyme is produced from the beads. And that's the really active
anti-inflammatory. Very strong for you, important to help heal the liver as well. We use it a lot
for patients with any cancer that's metastasized to the liver, any cancer that's causing pain
because it's such a strong anti-inflammatory. That's what there I know the company's really pushing it
just as a straight anti-inflammatory for pain. And of course, they're trying to be very careful in what
they're making claims, which I really appreciate with this company, they're making these extraordinary
claims. But would you hear testimonies like this going from 20 and a day to zero by taking a natural
anti-inflammatory that's also going to help your liver. Pretty amazing story right there.
We should make anybody try this product that has, you know, ongoing pain of any sorts.
So you started taking this, you dropped your anvil, consumption down to zero or next to zero.
That was how long ago, 70 years ago you said? That was about seven and a half years ago. And you know,
what I learned is that that ingredient is betaline. And there's betaline is in carrots,
betalins, in red beans. Betaline, there's a few ways to get betaline in your system. The
challenge is you have to eat a whole lot of carrots and carrots also have a lot of sugar. And the same
with red beans. So to get the betaline, that core ingredient that reduces that inflammation,
to get enough of it, you'd be consuming so much sugar, you're doing yourself a disservice because
whether it's beet powder, beet juice, or just the natural organic beet fantastic, you're getting
it some benefit. But Cornell University had, it was a five year, five million dollar study to find
out what was nature's number one anti-inflammatory. And it ended up being the betaline ingredient.
The challenge was the betaline and the red beet also was attached with all the sugar. And of course
sugar increases inflammation. So what evolved health and their partners were able to do was to, as
you said, have that patent that naturally extracted the betaline ingredient from the rest of the beet,
from the sugar. So in that capsule, just said tiny capsule, they say it's 500 cooked red
beads worth of betaline without the sugar. And that's the whole idea. It's not what is the best
antioxidant or anti-inflammatory in the test tube? The studies were on what was best in the human
body. And I'm very thankful for that. So then what happened for me is that because the inflammation
released from my back and my ankles and mostly my feet, of course we can't make medical claims,
but I was battling what the medical industry would call plantar fasciitis. And it was so, I mean,
it literally was so painful in my feet that I was winsing in pain every step I took to do my
maintenance from. So of course what happens then is you're less active. Well, when you're less
active, what happened for me is I gained 40 pounds of fat. Well, yeah, that 40 pounds of fat on
two feet. Yeah, so then what happened, Dr. Calvin, because my feet felt better and I had more
natural energy. Again, I got back to being active over the next handful of months. I lost all 40
pounds of that fat. I have not had an ad bill since. And the nicest part about it is I've been able
to maintain my health. I haven't gained any weight back. I haven't had any bolts with pain or
inflammation since. So it's been a phenomenal product for our family, you know, for seven and a half
years. And with that, our family has expanded. And you know, when our son was teething my wife, you
know, with her background and and health and education, you know, she would just open up that capsule
and put it in his, in his milk. So we didn't have to, at any time possible, my wife was going to take
the natural route, the challenge is sometimes a natural route. People don't think it's that effective.
So what are the most effective natural ingredients or natural foods? And I know that's what you
spent 30, 40 years of your career on Dr. Kevin is finding out what are the most impactful natural
foods, ingredients and solutions to people's health challenges. But until people have someone in
their lives, I mean, I think most people are like me where they think they know or they kind of know
some of the ideas of good health. But until they put experts in their life like yourself or my wife
or some of the other people that were blessed to be in contact with, we really don't have any idea.
And quite honestly, with all the information that is online, you think our country are beginning
healthier. But from what I've read the last three years in a row, our life expectancy has actually
gone down in America. Yeah. Yeah, you touched on a lot of great points there. Our life expectancy,
this generation is going to be the first generation in over the years that is going to have a shorter
life expectancy than their parents. Pretty sad. And it is a lot of misinformation out there. And
partly, maybe a lot to do with the profit driven companies that are not really trying to produce
something that's really beneficial in the end game. It doesn't have studies behind it.
You know, your testimony and testimonies like this really help drive good nutrition.
Because I do think there's a lot of people that are misled in that they get maybe a bad taste
of their mouth because something that they spent a lot of money on didn't work. So when you hear
great testimonials, that is motivating factor. Appreciate all this Brian. We got to have you
on again to talk about some of the other great products that we use with evolves. You have
you know, testimonies yourself or herd of testimonies from your CBD product and the
evolved immune product and some of the other things too. Anything else you want to leave people with?
Well, I would just say, you know, I think in my 20s, a friend just had pointed out that our brain
is like a sponge. And there's only so much we can fit in that sponge. There's only so much we
can fit in our brain. If we try to do all of these self-studies ourselves, I don't even think we
have enough room in our brains for it. That's why we put good at counts in our life. That's why we
put good holistic doctors in our lives. That's why we put good people that we can trust in the
education and information. And well, I love what you and your staff are doing. Dr. Kevin is exactly that.
I mean, 20, 30, 40 years of rock solid experience and education. And the best thing I've ever heard
is there's just no way for any of us to know everything. So pick those experts that are on your
team that are in your corner, you know, investing their entire lives to be educated in order to
transfer that to people like myself. That's what I would say. It's just put those great people in your
life and actually do what they recommend. Yeah. Better have had, take six months for your wife to
dig, right? Right, right. Exactly. Well, praise God that that all happened. That you're back on your
feet and inflammation is down. Great testimony. Well, have you back on? Very soon. Thanks for the
time that you're giving us. I appreciate it. And we will talk again. Thank you very much, Dr. Kevin
Conner. It's an honor and we're excited to help people all over the world with you.